all-out effort by President Trump to
rewrite the administration's response to
the corona virus outbreak at his longest
White House briefing so far this thing
was over two hours the president showed
a campaign style video highlighting what
he says or his accomplishments millions
of Americans are feeling the pain of the
pandemic more than a thousand died
yesterday bringing the total to 23,000
since the crisis began at least 17
million Americans have applied for
unemployment benefits Paula Reid
questioned the president yet at
yesterday's briefing she joins us now
from the White House good morning Paula
a good morning Anthony yesterday's
briefing began with the president
insisting that dr. Anthony Fauci job is
not in jeopardy
despite retweeting calls for him to be
fired just hours earlier ouchy was then
called to the podium where he recanted
statements he had made over the weekend
that appeared to criticize the
administration's response to coronavirus
with that out of the way the lights in
the room were dimmed and a video was
played criticizing the media and
praising the president's response
everything we did was right President
Trump was adamant that neither he nor
his administration did anything wrong in
their response to the corona virus
pandemic and he lashed out at what he
called unfair reporting and I don't mind
being criticized but not when they're
wrong the president played this more
than three-minute campaign-style video
produced by White House staff it shows a
timeline suggesting his response to the
virus was ahead of the curve but the
video also includes a month long gap in
the administration's response jumping
from February 6th when the CDC first
shipped test kits to March 2nd when
companies began testing a vaccine the
argument is that you bought yourself
some time you didn't teach us to prepare
hospitals you didn't use it to ramp up
testing it's so disgraceful the way you
said it
let me just listen I just went over it I
just
nobody thought we should do it and what
I did it what do you do when you have no
case in a whole United States when you
hear excuse me you reported it zero
cases zero deaths On January 17 On
January 30 and in fact we'll give you a
list what we did in fact part of it was
up there we did a lot you know you're a
fake you know that your whole network
the way you cover it is fake in February
the president held several campaign
rallies and continued to downplay the
threat looks like by April you know in
theory when it gets a little warmer
miraculously goes oil but more than
1,600 people tested positive in 47
states before the president declared the
outbreak a national emergency on march
13th when somebody's the President of
the United States the authority is total
the president also insisted that he has
the authority to lift stay at home
orders issued by state's new york
Governor Andrew Cuomo pushed back on the
president saying the Constitution says
we do not have a king and in a direct
challenge to the president's authority
to groups of state governors one on the
East Coast one on the West Coast states
hit hardest by the virus announced that
they will band together to make their
own decisions about how to roll back
these restrictions Tony and will be
following those as well Paula Reid for
us Paula thank you very much